Tampa Police hoped that new surveillance
video will lead them closer to
identifying a possible serial killer
this footage shows a person of interest
running from one of three murder scenes
the three victims were shot and killed
just days apart DeMarco Morgan is in
Tampa Florida where investigators are
finding other clues in this case DeMarco
good morning good morning Gail police
have been sifting through security video
and they're asking homeowners in this
neighborhood with security cameras to
turn over any video of suspicious
activity we believe that this person has
ties to this neighborhood that person of
interest is seen in this surveillance
video running from the spot where
Benjamin Mitchell was murdered he was
shot just seconds earlier I've come up
with four reasons why this person is
running one they may be late for dinner
two they're out exercising three they
heard gunshots and number four they just
murdered Benjamin Mitchell and another
video before the murder that same person
is seen flipping a cell phone an
important clue for investigators the
reason I focus in on the flip because
that might be a habit of this person the
other two victims include 20-year old
Anthony Noboa and thirty two old Monica
Hoffa all shot and killed within ten
days of each other and Tampa Seminole
Heights neighborhood police haven't
swarm in the area
warning the community to keep vigilant
we're stopping and talking to just about
anybody who we see it's a scary thing
Tampa mayor Bob Buckhorn is urging
anyone with holding information to come
forward all you're doing is protecting a
killer and that killer may take out one
of your family members so you decide
which side you're on police of totosai
have received 350 tips there is a 35
thousand dollar reward for any
information leading to an arrest
Nora all right DeMarco thank you so much